hi Emmanuel how's it going just fine
Martin I heard you had some questions
about I am for Google Cloud yes there
are some I am related things that I've
heard mentioned so many times that I'm
afraid to ask uh could you explain them
to me
no problem I'd be happy to help
[Music]
first off the term IAM confuses me a
little it's something to do with Access
Control right right so I am a short for
identity and access management I am is a
collection of tools that allows
administrators to Define who can do what
on which resources in a Google Cloud
project all right that's helpful uh but
could you give us an example sure here's
a cloud run service that I built that
reads buckets from Google Cloud Storage
now for it to work the administrator
needs to granted access to the cloud
storage service if it doesn't have that
access the cloud run service won't work
all right I've built lots of cloud run
Services both demos and actual
production applications I loved later on
because it lets me run containers in the
cloud without having to maintain virtual
machines or learn kubernetes but I
haven't really touched IEM for them I
just left all the defaults on so there's
one panel in the cloud run console that
I need your help with the manual sure
which one it's this panel which is about
permissions for my cloudron service
Emmanuel please explain this panel to me
like I'm five like you're five okay I'll
give it a go uh these are the rules that
can trigger your Cloud run service if
you click the carrot next to a row you
will see which principles have that role
okay I see Cloud run invoker roll here
if I click it I see all users what does
that mean so the principle all users
means that anyone on the internet who
knows the URL of this service can
trigger it okay I get it and what
happens if I enable this called uh show
inherited permissions sure inherited
permissions is another way of saying
permissions defined for the project now
if you click the owner you see your name
there which means you have the right
access to trigger the service so because
I have owner access to the project I
automatically get access to trigger
Cloud run Services that's your right
those project permissions like owner
simplify things now if you create a
hundred new Cloud run services in your
project you automatically get access to
them because you're the project owner
you don't have to add yourself manually
to each Cloud run service so anyone
who's owned on the project has access to
everything within the project absolutely
correct there are three basic or
primitive roles for projects someone
with the owner Road can do pretty much
anything on a project the editor role
lets you edit most resources in the
project but not set permissions or set
up billing for the project only the
project owner can do that and then there
is a project viewer role which lets you
see anything in a project but not change
anything
I see it sounds like those basic roles
give out a lot of permissions they do so
these roles were introduced before IM
was a service in Google Cloud they give
very broad permission so it's best that
you use more granular roles now this
webpage explains how to do that um Ah
that's a lot clearer now then there is
this button here that says add principle
let's see clicking it now what is this
doing it lets you select the principle
and give it a role so for example you
can enter a co-worker's email address
and give them the cloud run admin role
so they can view they can edit delete
and Trigger this particular Cloud run
service you can also give other common
roles to principles here like project
owner editor or viewer call it I think I
don't understand how IM works for
individual resources and for a project
uh but most customers I've talked with
have many projects so they typically
have one project for the dev environment
of the application and now they're for
the test environment a third for the
production environment and then multiply
that by the number of applications they
run that's a lot of projects how can
they keep those roles and principles
straight for all those projects so now
typically you create an organization in
Google Cloud for your company now under
your organization you have folders which
you can map to departments you can also
associate these folders with projects
and then you assign resources to a
project you can set policies for
organizations folders or projects
okay that sounds useful uh could you
give us an example
sure so now if your organization has a
devops team that works on specific
projects there could be a folder with
those projects in it if I work on the
devops team I would have a certain level
of access to that folder which gives me
the same level of access to all projects
in it ah I got it but what if your
devops team has like 20 people in it and
everyone in that team should have access
to multiple folders wouldn't it get
messy to add and remove individuals to
all of those folders yes it definitely
would in this case you would use groups
a group is a collection of users now
these users can be granted the same
permissions by attaching a role to that
specific group then when someone changes
teams you can just remove them from one
and add them to another this makes it
easy to manage users at scale okay that
makes sense
now we've only talked about who is
allowed to trigger our Cloud run service
so it runs the other side of the coin is
what the cloud run service is allowed to
do when it's running
tell me how that works sure click
revisions for your Cloud run service and
then security here you see the account
used by your Cloud run service now your
Cloud run service is allowed to do
anything that this account can do okay
and what is this account
okay so this account uh is the default
compute service account in your project
if you don't specify a particular
account when you create your Cloud run
service this is the default account used
see if you can figure out what roles
this account has
all right uh I click I am under the
hamburger menu here
uh there is the account uh looks like it
has project editor access
that's right now because it has the role
of project editor it can do pretty much
anything in the project like creating
virtual machines or databases oh that's
a lot of access most of my cloud run
Services don't need all of that right so
this is the default because it makes it
easy to get things working in a
development environment now in a
production environment you should make
sure that each Cloud run service has the
minimum level of access it needs to do
its job this is also referred to as the
principle of least privilege I have
heard that term before uh now I have a
cloud run service here that only needs
to read and write to the datastore
database how would I configure minimum
permissions for it
okay so you click the service in Cloud
run then the edit and deploy new
revision button and then security all
right I'm there now uh here I can see
that the service uses the default
compute service account you were talking
about
okay so look let's fix that click on the
service account drop down and then the
create new service Account button uh
looks like the console suggested an
account name that is the same as my
cloudron service name if you have a
special service account for each Cloud
run service that has the same name as
that service it's easy to keep track of
the accounts now click create here you
can answer what role this new account
should have
my cloud run service only needs to read
and write to the datastore database I
will enter data store here looks like
there is a role called Cloud datastore
user that can read and write to
datastore I'll pick that one very good
now click done you can see that the
service account drop down has changed to
the account you just created the cloud
run service will run as that account
click deploy and this change will take
effect
so if bad codes somehow makes it into my
cloudron service it can only do damage
to datastore it can do other things like
destroy virtual machines or shut down
other Cloud run services and that's
exactly right thanks for explaining
Emmanuel now if you'll excuse me I think
I need to go and tighten access for some
of my cloud run services
happy to help Martin and thank you
everyone for watching if you have
questions for a manual or me please add
them in the comments also do let us know
if there are other serverless topics
you'd like to hear about in future
episodes until next time
[Music]